[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of congratulations
[Music]
here we are it's episode 251 and i know
that because episode 250 was the last
one is that right or am i wrong good we
got it i knew it but then i went you
know i was a little insecure and then i
asked one fire and he came through with
the [ __ ] so on fire when one fire comes
through with the shits one higher um
so we're starting the episode now and
it's it's
you know absolute legitness so far
we've got uh
shows coming up i'm going to be in
atlanta georgia september
9th
washington dc september 10th
september 23rd and 24th i'll be in
stockton california and oakland
california october 7th and 8th i'll be
in peoria illinois and rockford illinois
october 21st i'll be in raleigh north
carolina october 22nd savannah georgia
november 5th i'll be in denver colorado
cheyenne wyoming and then november 12th
boston massachusetts december 3rd
jacksonville florida go to
crystallia.com and get those tickets
they're going fast
love you guys did phoenix was was so
great got the vlog out now or whatever
you want to call it i don't know if it's
technically a vlog or not i don't know
if i do vlogs or what if what it is it
might just be videos i might just do
videos i don't know what a vlog is i
don't know what a [ __ ] youtuber is
maybe i'm a youtuber maybe i'm a maybe
i'm an absolute youtuber
um
and either way dude he's pushing forward
he pushes forward he does some shows he
does more shows and he pushes forward
uh to get out of the darkness and we are
good um so chrisley.com for shows and
we've got merch too we've got uh the
merch popping off chrisley.com go to
chrisley.com chance to win that jacket
the life rips um
uh letterman jacket which is absolutely
i mean it's the drippiest [ __ ]
what are we gonna do it's a drippy as
[ __ ] so
i mean you know you put that on you go
whoopsie daisy it's the drippiest [ __ ]
dude so um
yeah man phoenix was beautiful did we
talk about phoenix last time
or did we we did we talked about phoenix
last time i just keep thinking about it
because i keep thinking about how
wonderful it was and i don't use that
word lightly i don't you know i keep
thinking about how wonderful it was
being with my son
um
i went on a boat
i went on a boat dude oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
pack up we got to go
i went on a [ __ ] boat it was
somebody's birthday party and i went on
a [ __ ] boat
gotta go dude smooth sailing baby
didn't want to go wanted to support a
friend when had a good time dude now i
go on boats
you know what i mean so if you want to
talk to me about boats i'll be like well
i was on one that was made in the 60s
the other day and i like when it's
choppy do it and someone's like you want
a motion sickness pill and i go like
this no and they say well what if it
makes you nauseous and i say it won't i
move around
constantly and they say fine but keep
your eye on the horizon
didn't and didn't up chuck
i don't get [ __ ] emotion sickness
that's for the birds i know it's in her
ear
in her ear [ __ ] but also dude my energy
my inner ear is all gravy man both of
them
my inner ear
is all gravy both of them
so the choppy [ __ ] was going crazy and i
was standing and guess what i guess what
i realized my core is way better than i
thought it was i got balance i mean i'm
crazy i'm like a gymnast walking the
beams and everyone's like why aren't you
holding on i'm like oh i guess i don't
need to
dude and i'm the only smart guy that
wore a [ __ ] hoodie in sweats everyone
was throwing up in [ __ ] shorts on a
you know what i mean one of those tommy
bahama shirts i'm like just watch how
cold you are i showed up the dude on the
boat was like the dude that was working
on the boat he was like oh dude you
dressed you dressed perfect man and i
was like [ __ ] man am i a boat guy
so i got on the boat dude and yeah he
wore the yamiri [ __ ] and it's fine and
he also wore the amiri pants i know you
thought of but it's all good man did
they match yeah dude it's fine man
but he's so [ __ ] ridiculously hot
he's practically up and coming
oh [ __ ] but he's 42 but he's youthful
right
but he's sitting on the boat and he's up
at the top and nobody's there and it's
fine because he's feeling all good by
himself
hey guys come up here he said nobody
hurt him because of the whirr of the
[ __ ] engine of the boat come up here
he said again and still nobody heard him
so he stayed up there like a [ __ ]
captain and just took in the sea dude
oh i took in the sea
standing there with a miri top and
bottom just taken in the sea not being
nauseous at all dude
it was [ __ ] unreal sunsets are
beautiful at sea
and now i know that
i went below deck i went above deck and
i went on to the triple part dude i went
up to the [ __ ] second upper deck dude
it was it was really great
there was crazy like [ __ ] music and
it was too loud but i was enjoying
myself you know and i don't even know
it's you know
i got there and i was like how am i
gonna do this right i was like how am i
gonna do this and my buddy mike was
there and he was just like oh i show up
i showed up i walked up because i locked
the car and i walked up afterwards and i
showed up and he was like yo what's up
you're just like a cool guy or what you
think you're cool and i was like no what
do you mean he was like i don't know you
just like walk up and people are like
who's that i'm like what the [ __ ] you
talking about i'm just walking and he's
like yeah but you know it and i'm like
bro why don't you just chill and he was
like ah whatever i've never been that
guy and i'm like you got it it's deeper
you got issues he's like yeah there was
a guy in [ __ ] high school that was
always like that man and i [ __ ] was
like why is he like that i'm not like
that and i'm like said deeper but then
i'm introspective right
maybe i wasn't introspective three years
ago but now wall's down i started
thinking about why am i that guy am i
putting people at arm length what's
important is
i'm chilling
right
i'm relaxed in myself and i'm chilling
right no walls up i mean people don't
have to know everything about me but
they need to get my energy they need to
understand me
and my energy
so i was like what do i do man and i was
sitting around and kristen looks at me
and she's like
you want to vive ants and i'm like
great
i'm being a piece of [ __ ]
i'm being a piece of [ __ ] dude she's
like you in a vivance
you seem
he's a piece of [ __ ] he's standing in a
parking lot he's a piece of [ __ ]
so i just go like this you know i never
did drugs in my life ever i never
[ __ ] did prescription drugs in my
life ever so i was like okay fine uh
i've you know in the past two years i i
took my first [ __ ] xanax so i'm like
you know what sometimes he's a zany boy
he likes to [ __ ] trot out to zany
island right
he goes like there's one ticket to zany
island i'll be back when i can i don't
know when it when the when the when the
boat comes back but he'll you know what
i mean
not the boat that i was on but the
[ __ ] proverbial boat i don't even
know if that's right word but i've heard
people say it so i'm like look
vyvance whatever you know one time she
gave me a little bit of it a half of
when i took it did nothing so i was just
like she was like you want to have
advance and i go like this man this is
either going to be the [ __ ] time or
the best time 5 doesn't work and i just
go like this give me the whole thing
she gives it to me i pop it in my mouth
i take a swig of my iced americano now
that's how you know i mean business
because i don't do an ice americano and
take it with a pill ever i don't do that
because i feel more dry and then i need
to take more water
and i you know these are just this is
the minutia of my life the basic [ __ ]
that you don't need to know about but
that you secretly need to know about
because that's me right so i take the
[ __ ] [ __ ] i take it with the ice
americano now i'm dry as [ __ ] and i'm
pissed i took it because now i'm extra
dry didn't want to take a sip of the ice
americano washed it down the vivance is
here
okay
now we walk on the vote on the boat not
vote because vote is nothing not when it
comes to boats
so i say can i have the can can i can we
get another thing they're like do you
want anything i said water i took the
water go go go go the vivants travels
down my esophagus
the boat starts going this chop starts
hitting new friends start introducing
themselves and all of a sudden dude your
boy
happens to be
by mistake
oopsy daisy whoops i slipped and fell
and became
the life of the party
[Music]
now whoops
the boat's going he entered the dent
they're [ __ ] chopping you guys like
it's choppy now i'm just standing there
they want to take a picture and i'm game
dude they want us to pose for it now you
know me i like candid shots you're not
going to see too many pictures of me
like this
you might see something like this
because i like candid shots when someone
says get together i go like this in my
head i go oh why don't you just capture
the moment
why are we creating a moment when
moments just exist on top of each other
get this moment
but your boy took a vivance so he's
posing for pictures like he's goddamn
drake dude
[Music]
so he's careful with the vivants you
know he took one vive ants and he takes
some days off because he's not going to
be a vivants boy i mean he's a vivance
boy on a boat
right
he's the vivants boy at sea
but dude he's not a five hands boy
anyway i had a great time dude i showed
everybody what was up with my core not
holding on to railings unless i
absolutely needed to i almost fell off
the boat once you know but that's not
even my fault because the ship was so
choppy and then i said to the guy yo
people must fall off the boat all the
time and he said only men that are six
feet and above because their center of
gravity is higher and we have to [ __ ]
go and get them and i'm like jesus
christ dude imagine falling off a boat
how harrowing and you know what just
kill me right there if i fall off a boat
i'm dead don't find me i'm done dude i
get it dude go bye i lost it's all good
i had a good run
you know how scary it would be to fall
off a [ __ ] boat and just see them go
and they don't even know everyone's so
drunk
wait where the [ __ ] is chris where's
vivance boy what the [ __ ]
what happened to the dude
uh uh just [ __ ] cloaked out in amiri
gear
what happened to [ __ ] drip central
oh the amir is weighing them down it's
weight it's wet now
yeah man so we had a good time man we
had a good [ __ ] time
and there were 25 people on that boat
and uh it was somebody's birthday and we
had a good time and you know for sure
there was coveted all over that boat let
me tell you the number one thing there's
a there is on that is on a boat covet
maybe in 19 in 2019
the most thing that would be on a boat
are like carnation pink short pants but
now kovid
kovid took over the boat game kova goes
like this yeah
okay carnation shorts we got this
2020 came in and kovit goes like this
i see those carnation pink shorts
move aside kids who have dads that are
lawyers
we've got it from here
[ __ ] covet showing covert showing up
to the boat with a bunch of pink
carnation shorts dude
[Music]
people start
for real man covered showing up to the
boat dude
coven showing up to the boat pink
carnation shorts going like this
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah dude
amazing colvin's showing up to the boat
dude colvin showing up to the boat with
the [ __ ] with the with the with with
the pink carnation shorts aplenty right
here
[Music]
[Applause]
and then everyone
dude coven showing up oh
canvas music
i mean what else do you want from me
dude
i'm a vyvance boy
dripped out in amiri
um so i did that
you know somebody was like you know
hey you're having a lot of fun and i'm
just like all right dude am i i'm a drug
addict too i have no [ __ ] idea and of
course it was a coke or heroin or you
know
but uh there's great drugs out there and
i only do it responsibly with a
prescription i have a prescription so
go [ __ ] yourself if you're like well
chris be careful i mean there's gonna be
inevitably i know you i want you to out
to um activate the algorithm and leave
comments and become friends in the
comments and you can let me know what
you think but i know people are going to
be like i mean there's always that one
guy well chris be careful with that
vivance my aunt took it and she you know
what i mean and i'm just like yeah but
i'm not your aunt dude
it's not like i'm going nutty snorting
it dude
i should snort it
don't snort it
um
so i like a boat and then of course
kristen is just like we should get a
boat
can a chick go on a boat without saying
we you know what
you know
the number one thing a chick says on an
on a boat is you know what it's not even
we should get a boat it's you know what
like that anytime you hear your girl say
you know what you're in you're losing
[ __ ] 20 g's at least if you're if
you're a rich dude
and if you're not a rich dude you're
losing [ __ ] 800 dollars
there's a sliding sc you know what
you know we should do oh just you know
what put your hands in my pockets [ __ ]
it
you got my car you know what i just you
got my card
that's what the the response is for that
i'm not getting a boat you know you know
where we should oh dude we just got
gotta drive through a nice neighborhood
you know what it wouldn't be half bad
liv you know what
what why don't you do you everybody
would you ever
move to the marina
we're building a house in [ __ ]
the san fernando va yeah but we could
say you know what if we sell the lot and
we're already doing it dude
we paid the [ __ ] deposit
you know what i mean
files done
for no reason didn't know what it was
had to look at it
so yeah dude
i told this story on lifeline and i'm
going to tell it my way too so my
brother doesn't interrupt me he doesn't
interrupt me he's great but i'm just
going to tell my version of it do it
because some of you don't listen to the
lifeline if you listen to lifeline you
got to listen to life if you don't
listen to lifeline you got to listen to
lifeline it's my new podcast with my
brother and we take advice and we take
questions and we give advice to it and
it and it rips it's just great it's
already bonkers crazy it's going [ __ ]
dummy viral so it's all good man you
know and that's not my fault dude if the
people want to watch it they want to
watch it and i don't want to be like a
dick but you're welcome but also thank
you right
it's a symbiotic relationship
i get into the [ __ ] i'm going to
lifeline and i'm like you know what have
i called the producer i was like yo can
you please order me one of those
burritos from that banging place i can't
do it because you know postmates you can
order from another place on postmates
but it's always more difficult because
they're like are you actually at this
place or you're far away like you're an
idiot you're like just [ __ ] send it
where i'm guessing all right at least
make it on me don't
it's just so i'm like can you just ha
just can i get can you get the thing get
the vegan burrito and your boy eats meat
i don't want you to think i'm some woke
[ __ ] i don't want you to think i'm some
guy that's quote unquote in tune with
his body and spiritual i'm not dude as a
matter of fact i don't even have a
spirit okay
so uh they're like uh i'm like can you
just get me the vegan burrito and the
only reason is because it's good and i
don't want to have something heavy
before i bang it out on all cylinders on
lifeline okay
it's also on this channel subscribe to
the channel by the way we love you
subscribe to the channel
click that [ __ ] right now thank you i
love you
but i get to [ __ ] lifeline and uh uh
you know he orders it he goes yo gotcha
burrito will be here get there to the
building as soon as i get to the
building guy shows up with a postmates
bag [ __ ] yeah dude johnny great timing
okay i walk in is the bag i judge the
size of the bag i know i only got one
burrito and nobody else got anything
because i'm on a group text and everyone
said nay now i look it's a [ __ ] size
of a burrito my baby
so i'm happy dude
johnny great timing
so we get into the elevator and sure
enough what button does the guy hit well
the guy with the burrito hits the same
button that i'm going to hit
because he's going to the same floor i'm
going to go because that's my burrito
he's holding
but i have options here right
i could either
say
yo i think that's my order and have him
be like okay and then wait till we both
get to the door so i prove it to him
because obviously i'm not just so i'm
not just wack job in an elevator
and then he hands me the burrito as i
walk into my my the door that we're both
going to or
i could not say anything
which is a little bit weird because
it'll seem like i'm following him until
we get to the door
and then i have to be like hey that's my
burrito
and also it makes me seem
not observant
now i don't want either of those things
i don't like awkwardness and it takes a
lot for making me to feel awkward dude
i've stood on a stage bombing in front
of hundreds of people okay
i can handle being in an awkward
elevator ride as a matter of fact has
there ever been an elevator ride that
isn't awkward i got this
but i don't want him to feel like i'm
not perceptive or observant
so he hits the floor boom doors
we're trapped and i choose to say ah
is that the burrito
and he says yup
and i say
it's mine
and he goes
we go up high of course we go up high we
go up real high because we're at the top
of the floor because we're no [ __ ]
dude
we don't have a studio ground level
we've got
a studio above the clouds
and the reason is
because we're not a bunch of [ __ ]
okay we swallow hard and we move forward
pause
we swallow hard
pause
we swallow hard and the only direction
we look
is up
pause
we take copious loads in our throats
and say thanks dude
pause
we suck large amounts of [ __ ]
they get off in our mouths and then we
turn around and they take turns on our
anus
paws
okay
then we hold hands and we watch
america's sweethearts
pause
but that's the kind of [ __ ]
gangsters we are right
now i don't even know at the beginning
of that [ __ ] run what the hell i was
talking about but that's all
so that's what happened so we so he so
he chuckles you know because we're both
in the same elevator he's got the
postmates for me and a [ __ ] upsy
daisy dude it comes to a screeching halt
oh he's got gucci shoes on
what the [ __ ]
this doesn't
add up the profile of this guy it
doesn't add up
cause who's
uber eats in or postmates in and some
gucci flip flops
maybe somebody but that guy has bad
priorities and fine
but that's what i judge this guy is but
i used my mind
and my intuition to think something's up
right like if that guy all of a sudden
beat the [ __ ] out of me i'd be like
should have known had some postmates
with the gucci flip-flops on that's on
me
trust her intuition
so
we get out of the elevator boom
on the same floor we walk down the
hallway to where it splits i go one way
he goes the other way now that's okay
and let me tell you why because this guy
doesn't even know this building he's my
postmates guy but then i'm like i'm
hearkening back to the days where i
asked this dude in the elevator is that
the burrito he replied yes and then i
said that's mine so he knows he should
follow me
why did he split off
so i'm looking over my shoulder like i'm
batman i'm looking over my shoulder like
i'm in a comic book
or a movie made by [ __ ] you know zack
snyder which i'm i'm not i'm absolutely
not in a movie name
made by zack snyder but if somebody were
to tap on his shoulder i'm the dude that
looks behind like this you ever see in
movies when a [ __ ] jackass gets
touched on the shoulder they always look
at the hand first and then at the guy
that's by the way the most asinine and
dangerous way to look at somebody who
just [ __ ] basically assaulted you
from behind
if you look at the oh he looked i was
going to look at the [ __ ] thing
shanking his eyeballs glug glugging out
shank in his throat [ __ ] glue
glugging out right
sorry dude you looked at the hand not my
face you could have defended yourself
but now you're glug glugging out
you're busting off like a sprinkler on
the side of your neck excuse me are you
a ventriloquist
so anyway dude
he splits off and i'm like alright maybe
he didn't hear me or whatever but then
he gets into another apartment
and that's when your boy realized oh
[ __ ]
this sucks
i was wrong
he lives here
and he was carrying his own food into
his apartment
and we just had the moment that i wanted
to not make awkward
turned into a very awkward moment
and your boy felt it
because i looked at a dude
pointed to his food that he just picked
up
in a small confined space
and said
hey bud
that's mine
hey hey man what kind of [ __ ] lunatic
does that and i'm proud of myself dude
i'm honestly proud of myself
because i did something so cool and so
insane and i didn't even know it and my
life's the same so what i'm trying to
get at is i'm gonna do more [ __ ] like
that
i'm gonna do more [ __ ] like that [ __ ] it
why not why not walk into an elevate a
lot of people learn from their mistakes
well let me tell you what i learned
during this mistake i'm just gonna say
whatever the [ __ ] i want to anyone
because it doesn't matter he just
laughed
what a [ __ ] he is huh
and his gucci flip-flops why didn't he
say what do you mean dude if i was in an
elevator and i had my food that i just
picked up and some dude looks at me and
says is that a burrito
by the way it probably wasn't a burrito
it could have been anything maybe it was
because he said yes and i and then the
guy said that's mine i'd say what do you
mean
hey buddy help me clear this situation
up how about
oh we bugs bunny and yosemite sam
because we're some looney tunes now
and i wasn't even on [ __ ] vyvance
and then i waited for a little bit
longer and the [ __ ] producer was like
i don't know what's up here bruto it's
taking a long time and then i told him
the story and then i said it again on
lifeline and that's the third that's the
fourth time i told it because i also
told it to my family hey yes he is john
he tells the same story too much dude
but that's what comedians do and that's
how when they realize maybe i should say
it on stage and now i probably won't
because i said it on two pockets yes
dude people will think they're ripped
off if they come see me live dude i
actually heard that stuff on my podcast
on the podcast whatever man don't push
me you can get don't push me merch at
crystallia.com
what's up dude
your boy's changing your boy's living
your boy's growing
he doesn't stop the second you think you
got life figured out that's when the
cookie [ __ ] explodes that's not a
saying i didn't want to say that's when
the cookie crumbles i should have said
that's when the cookie crumbles but
you know me
and if you know me and if you listen to
every episode of this podcast or other
podcast you know i haven't had taco bell
since i was what 19 that's 23
years
i haven't had taco bell in 23 years
23 years
you might be like well why don't you
just say 25 why don't you just say 20.
and i would reply because i know
it's been 23 years
and then you'd be like why and then i
say because i remember when i vowed
never to eat taco bell ever again and
then you might say well how do you know
exactly when that was but then i would
specifically say i was 19 because that's
when i was at nyu standing outside of a
taco bell that i just ate and i thought
you know what that wasn't that good i'm
never gonna eat this again and i'm gonna
remember this moment for the rest of my
life
what a [ __ ]
lunatic dude but i did it and i [ __ ]
stuck to it and i didn't realize that
that was my ocd in effect until a decade
and a half later dude
[Music]
he's got problems
ocd anxiety dark thoughts
sometimes when it gets real bad suicidal
ideation sometimes when it really gets
real bad suicide it's all good
not lately
your boy grows
he doesn't eat taco bell and he hasn't
done it in 20. now i haven't eaten
burger king in 15 years except for one
time they wanted to pay me
some [ __ ] racks to do a commercial
for him and you know your boy doesn't
say no to bags so he went back on his
ocd swallowed the anxiety swallowed the
big mac and carried some bags home okay
one fire shaking his head but you know
it's true it was a whopper not a big mac
because that's see that just goes to
show you that i don't really eat that
much fast food unless it comes to
[ __ ] in and out he shaked his head
because he shook his head because it's
not a big map it's a big mac it's a
whopper but i ate it dude and i thought
i wasn't gonna like it but then i put it
in there and i realized that [ __ ] is
chemically engineered to make you like
it and i liked it and i ha so i had one
burger one whopper in between the
[ __ ] dude this podcast is the most
interesting podcast if you're a part of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] and you're gripped
you're on the edge of your seat or
you're listening to your cubicle or
you're driving you're progressing you're
listening to me first of all you're a
cuck if you're in a prius but we love
cucks anyway dude we love them all man i
love you no matter what you're driving
dude yeah you're in a prius and you like
to watch your guy you like to watch your
wife get [ __ ] by other guys and maybe
you're on your way to go watch your uh
your friend [ __ ] your wife whatever it
is dude you're listening to me you're on
the edge of the seat you're listening
about my burger king stories and you are
with us dude this is basically the
virtual
tall grass outside of the log cabin and
you're wearing your white
and we're sharing our ideas and it's my
turn
but uh yeah dude burger king man took it
ate it and it's all good now i haven't
had taco bell in 23 years and of course
that's my ocd a little bit activated but
i still haven't done it and life's going
fine without the [ __ ] gordita so i
didn't get the gordita but i was hanging
out with a couple here we were at my
house hanging out with a couple dude
couples by the way i love the dude and
the couple and she loves the chicken the
couple so holy [ __ ] [ __ ] is that
heaven have you ever met a couple that
you hang out with and you both like them
both equally the same dude you gotta i
mean what the [ __ ] man you lucked out
the other person always suck imagine
being the [ __ ] fourth person that
sucks in a [ __ ] two two couples right
you don't even know you're that guy
you don't even know you're that guy yeah
but i [ __ ] i don't really i really
don't like dave honey
yeah but or she's like yeah but your
friend he's just like he's a mooch
and you're like yeah but he's [ __ ]
big my heart he's usually the dude you
know yeah he's been my homie for a long
time
so they came over we had a blast dude
we had a blast we had a good time we're
watching [ __ ] shows
by the way we watched the staircase we
watched the staircase dude we tried to
watch it with colin firth and you know
colin ferch what what's colin firth what
is he from he's from the [ __ ] uh uh
uh the [ __ ] political stutter or
whatever the [ __ ] that show's called
king speech
only person who could do the [ __ ]
king speech
role better than him is me i guarantee
it dude you put me in front of the [ __ ]
light
just waited on baited breath about what
i'm gonna [ __ ] say but i can't get it
out because of a condition
so anyway
so i get to the [ __ ] so we get we're
watching hbo max you know it's a good
streaming service i watch hbo max and
it's got the staircase and i like colin
firth and i like francis mcdormand dude
or whatever no not her i always mix her
up with tony collette they're the same
person pretty much whatever is that
sexist i don't know dude colin firth is
the same person as my dad when he was
50. so it's fine but colin firth is in
this [ __ ] he's one of those dudes he's
played an american it's it takes pla it
takes place in [ __ ] uh uh durham
carol north carolina it's a real story
about now i'll get back to the taco bell
stuff but you know how i go this is
my [ __ ] is like it's all splintered and
[ __ ] i tell a story i start telling the
story and i tell uh offshore an offshoot
of it i got this is an octopus story
right we start at the beak and then all
of a sudden he's using the tentacle to
to color the story and he'll get back to
it at the end we'll get back to the beak
but right now
we started a taco bell and we're talking
about this we're talking about a murder
or maybe not even a murder we don't know
the jury's cut well the jury was in and
then it was out and then he took a
[ __ ] alpha play and it's all he's out
of jail now but whatever dude it's a
show about a guy who maybe threw his
wife down the stairs we don't know or
bludgeoned her and then put it over at
the stairs and then she was [ __ ] dead
and they put him away for 15 years and
then decided to wait there's new
evidence and then [ __ ] took him out
of jail and he's like i never did it but
also two of his wives fell down the
stairs so it's like okay though hmm
when they figured that out right
so uh i'm watching the staircase and
colin firth is acting it up he's one of
those dude that's a fantastic actor but
no matter what he does he's british dude
you know he's just
too
british if you're that tall and that
lanky
you're just british
you know if you're an old guy and you're
just any they have you know he's got
glasses on because the real guy's got
glasses but also it makes you look more
british if you're that tall and lanky
and you got glasses and he's just like
so proper spoken and it's not even how
he's doing his accents good but behind
his accent is always like oh he's
british though he's got a british
feeling but he's doing his best and i
think he's doing a great job and he's
probably going to get nominated for an
emmy because nobody gives a [ __ ] about
anything and he's british and they give
emmys to so many brits although he is
white
so maybe he won't get an emmy
because people are really pushing that
whole [ __ ] you know
so i'm watching the staircase and it's
it's good but it's one of those shows
that
you're sitting and you're watching and
then you're like wait a second there's a
documentary about this isn't it
five and six of us are watching it the
couple
and my uh assistant and then another
no it was five of us
and there somebody said let's just watch
a documentary and i say i've already
seen it and they say i know but and then
the more i watch the [ __ ] staircase
and i'm like okay let's watch the
documentary i've seen the documentary
already and just for those of you that
think it came out on netflix for years
ago it didn't it came out on [ __ ]
somewhere else i bought it on itunes it
was the first thing i ever saw on an
ipod on one of those [ __ ] ipods with
the video it was the first thing i ever
saw on an ipod video this was like
whenever that came out 2006 2006 2004 i
have no idea
2010 whatever it was i watched it on the
plane like this dude
so small the screen's so small just
and the guy does a documentary
while he's out on bail saying how he
didn't push his wife down the staircase
now that seems like a [ __ ] ridiculous
idea just shut up if somebody thinks
you're accused of a crime hey practice
touching your top lip to your bottom lip
you know what i mean
hey did you do it
even if you didn't do it don't even say
no
just
let's play an exhibition game where your
top lip team
joins your bottom lip team
100 of the of the game right
because you're just gonna say some dumb
[ __ ]
did you do it no well where were you i
was at the pool well she died near the
pool well i okay i wasn't really near
the i was near the pool but i don't
think i could get there by the whoops
you're in a whole bunch of hot water
you could limit
that heat of the water by practicing
what say it with me touching your top
lip to your bottom lip
so anyway i'm watching this [ __ ] and i'm
like all right we'll take a vote
i'm in this show
i'm into the show on the hbo max [ __ ]
but let's [ __ ] take a vote
we take a vote dude
do we want to watch the staircase on hbo
max streaming with with with colin firth
or do we want to stop and start watching
the staircase which by the way we've
already seen
except i haven't seen the remaining two
extra episodes on netflix that came out
three years ago but i'm fine with that
because i'm over it dude you're not
gonna get me
i'm not no sucker
so they say
everyone votes for the [ __ ]
documentary and i go like this hold on i
want everyone to have all the info first
before we vote right because that's who
i am dude i like to get all this [ __ ]
out there and then take the real vote i
don't take the first bitch-ass vote we
talk about it and then take a real vote
so i say
we've seen two episodes of this
staircase streaming with colin firth
right
there's one episode left
that's out
that means
you know it goes to episode eight but
this is really important dude this is
the minutiae but this is so important
dude and if you're a fan of mine just
listen dude
i say
we have one more episode left on this
streaming [ __ ] it's 12 44 am and now i
remember this we're only gonna watch
another hour of television let's get to
this one and we watch the third episode
of the staircase we're all caught up
then we go to bed and maybe next time we
watch the documentary and we watch the
documentary until the new episode of the
staircase comes out or we just say screw
it and we start watching the documentary
and that's all i wanted to say i wanted
to say my piece now who wants to watch a
documentary everyone else it's like my
[ __ ] words were just
you know everyone documentary so i lost
but i lost at least i said my piece so i
go all right dude i'm a good guy i'm not
gonna [ __ ] stall in this [ __ ]
streaming [ __ ] if they don't want me to
[ __ ] you know what i mean mussolini
this streaming [ __ ]
so we switch platforms we watch netflix
yeah sure
he's got a bad taste in his mouth about
it but he turns it on and we start
watching the scare staircase and that's
when i learn about this new
oh there's two extra episodes and they
explain the owl theory
i know you know about this if you know
about the staircase
but there's a large
[ __ ] population online
of actual smart people that think
an owl flew in the window
attacked the woman's face she fell down
the stairs and then the owl kept
attacking her head
and that's how she died
and to the people who think that
my only response is
no
[Music]
i'm no detective
but no
[Music]
i'm no bloodspatter analysis
but no
[Music]
i'm no owl
but now
[Music]
the defense team was like well she could
have slipped and fall eight times
slippery that explains a pool of blood
in the blood on the souls she could have
slipped hit her head got back up coughed
on the wall slipped hit her head again
slipped hit her head again got back up
made a coffee come back slip a little
bit more watched some [ __ ]
watch some [ __ ] seinfeld
binged a little bit slipped fell some
more woke up did some [ __ ] jumping
jacks slip fell some more called her mom
slipped fell some more died blood out
or
her husband bludgeoned her with a
[ __ ]
poke what do you call him [ __ ]
stoker
um and uh look i don't know what
happened all i remember is when i saw it
back in 2000 and whatever i thought well
they didn't prove it
but he went to jail for 15 years
and it's like dude
get the [ __ ] owl on the stand you
know
imagine
hello mr uh owl i've got a few questions
for you
who me um
[Laughter]
i'd like to you do you know who was
living in the house uh
that you were allegedly near uh
objection your honor sustained do you uh
uh know uh the man that is a uh
being uh
prosecuted here who the man right over
there who that guy with the glasses
it's the man right there who me who well
i don't really honestly your honor know
how to get more specific who
your honor
who just the judge standing right here
okay i misspoke she's sitting and she's
wearing black she's right here
never mind so
where
where were you december 9th 2001 who
that's honestly not even a i'm not
talking about a person who
a person is like
oh chill chill chill
order who
you
100
the worst bit we've ever done on this
podcast dude
but [ __ ] yeah we do them and we're proud
we do them and we're proud dude
[ __ ] yeah we do them and we're proud
and you can sit there and laugh
yeah dude interview the owl get the owl
but then apparently there's people in
the south that's that it's actually a
big problem
owls really do sometimes attack these
people's faces because they feel like
they're threatened
every the southern people when they talk
you're just like okay
can we
no that's all i'm saying is that there
are owls out there that are
aggressive to
humans because
we are encroaching in there and you're
just
area and we have cut down some trees
that they do fancy living in
who
you
um
so we're watching the staircase and they
all get the idea and by they i mean the
girls
to order taco bell and i'm specifying
that it's girls because
you know
if there is a co-ed gathering going on
and somebody orders gets the idea or the
hankering for taco bell it's it's it's a
woman who's drank a little bit
you know
and the guys go sure
and then they eat more than the chicks
obviously because chicks you know
they'll do like half a [ __ ] cheesy
gordita and the dude's like
yo dude i'll house that
so they say do you want taco bell and
i'm a little bit offended because know
me friends no i don't want taco bell and
they say you sure and now i'm doubly mad
because i've already answered and you
also should know but also no and then
they say okay and then they go to order
and they say are you sure you don't want
anything and i don't say anything
because number one know me number two
also i answered it
and number three you're being
disrespectful now trust i know my
opinion
so i just stare and they go all right
so they get some cheesy gorditas and
some nachos and [ __ ] and it shows up
finally and it's way too late you know
the postmates driver is doing the thing
where he's like oh no that address
actually doesn't exist like they'll just
say [ __ ] sorry i'm late there was a
dragon in the way
post mates oh dude you know what
happened i don't care you might actually
there was a [ __ ] crystalia rally i was
trying to get through i actually believe
that sir
um
so anyway we get to the [ __ ] and they
get to the door they get to the door and
we get to the all the gorditas show up
and they're like and and they still you
want to bite and i'm like
look
you know this about me i haven't had
taco bell in 23 years and then my buddy
says how do you even know that and i go
through what i just told you i said you
know because i remember the moment and
your boy was 19 and it's probably an ocd
thing and whatever
and then kristen says
okay
will you please try this
what the [ __ ] is it called berry blast
do you know what it's called it's like
the new drink of taco bell baja blast
that's what it called baja blast
is baja a [ __ ] flavor
like
you know it's not right does anyone ever
[ __ ] try something and they're like
mmm tastes like baja
the [ __ ] out of here call it barry or
whatever
and i say no i'm not going to i'm not
going to i'm not going to drink that i
don't want to try a baja blast and she
says please i knew you're going to say
that but just try it for me and now i'm
put back on my heels why because why the
[ __ ] do you care so much what kind of
baja [ __ ] goes in my mouth
and she was like it's so good and i just
want you to experience it and i say this
is not really like the kind of
experience that i want to have
and she says please like for me and i
say why for you it's for me i just
because i want to share this and you're
growing and you're growing as a person
and you you're trying new [ __ ] and i say
[ __ ] i just went on a boat
you think just because
i'm not landlocked anymore that you can
just
throw a baja blast inside my face
no no no no no you're pushing your luck
see this is why i should have never got
on that boat right before you know it
i'll move to silver lake have a twisty
mustache a monocle and a top hat and
people will be asking me if they could
pass go
i'm me [ __ ]
so i'm like i don't want this baja blast
and she says please and i say babe look
i really i appreciate it i don't want
the baja blast and i say why do you want
me to have it if i don't want it just
because you don't know you know you
don't want it and i said i haven't had
taco bell in 23 years and she says but
this isn't even really taco bell and i
said where'd you get it
and she goes
and walks away and now i'm the bad guy
i don't consent to this taco bell though
he pressuring me
and then my buddy says you're a [ __ ]
idiot man it's so good and then i ask
his girlfriend and i say is it good and
she goes like this literally like this
and for the audio for the audio
listeners it was a very deep
uh
concerned look
and a nod up and down
like
i'd love to be on your side but this
baja blast is is really something to
write home about so now i'm like
everyone's against me dude i lost the
[ __ ] staircase hbo max traumatization
of the [ __ ] documentary and now i
[ __ ] i lost or watching documentary
and now i'm gonna lose to this baja
blasting but my ocd is strong but then i
realize it is my ocd and i said look
baby it's my ocd and she's like oh
really if it is then i won't bother and
now i feel like a [ __ ] so yes she's
winning all accounts yes not only on the
bad guy yes i'm a [ __ ] yes
he's a scared [ __ ] which is something
that his ex called him and that's when
he realized that was the end of his
relationship yes dude
you don't call someone a scared [ __ ]
unless you want the relationship to be
over and then i [ __ ] took it and for
a few weeks i lived with it and then
bill burr asked me how my relationship
was once at the ice house and i said
well it's weird because she asked me she
called me a scared [ __ ] and he said nah
you got to get rid of her and that's
when i realized
had to get rid of her
so thanks bill
so it's a deeper but i'm not a scared
[ __ ] and i'm not going to let the ocd
demon as they say control my life so i
say
i you know technically it's not really
from taco bell you can get that anywhere
so i [ __ ]
i mean i know they do specialize with
the baja blast but it's probably just
like sprite and [ __ ] you know spot
shot
and some ice so let me just [ __ ] you
know it's like neon i'm like i'm not
gonna look i'm not gonna like it i
promise
and then she goes well with that added
to it and i'm like no no i don't want
you to do that because i wasn't done
talking whoopsie daisy we interrupted me
if i drink it
i'm going to let my walls down i'm going
to sip it twice
and i'm going to absolutely give you the
god's honest truth from within my heart
and she says
okay and i say i'll try the baja blast
because it's not technically taco bell
it's kind of just in their drink system
so she says here
and i grab it
i smell it
because i want to know if i actually
sincerely don't want to drink it
because if it smells putrid i'm just not
gonna put it in my mouth i smell it it
passes the smell test it smells bad but
i'm like okay i'll do it i take one sip
i let it sit
i don't judge it yet because i'm not a
piece of [ __ ] dude
i take another sip
just like i said i was and my buddy's
girlfriend says ooh that means he likes
it and then of course i feel my blood
inside my heart because i said i'm gonna
take two sips to make a good judgment
and now she's trying to push an agenda
okay
so i take that second sip and i said no
i didn't take that
this kind of [ __ ] this is the kind of
[ __ ] life that i have this is the
[ __ ] that like we talk about
and i say no i said i was going to take
a second sip because i wanted to judge
it fairly because i told you i wanted to
judge it fairly and i'm a man of my word
okay
and she said
okay
i let it sit in my head i didn't just
taste it with my tongue i tasted it with
my head you ever taste something with
your whole head that's when you really
know how banging it is right you don't
just let it [ __ ] ruin it on your
palate you let it envelop your whole
[ __ ] head
i let it envelop my whole [ __ ] head
and it turns out
that the baja blast
from taco bell
is [ __ ] awful
and that's the god's honest truth so i
hand it back and i say it's awful and i
mean that with my heart and they go oh
come on and i say it tastes like windex
and i said to the guy does it taste like
windex or am i bullshitting and he goes
like this i mean you know and i go ah
so it does taste like windex a little
bit it's not good dude
i hate to say i told you so but i gave a
god's honest review of the baja blast
and it's bad
so [ __ ] yeah now i kind of i danced with
taco bell right i didn't take taco bell
but i danced with it in the soft
moonlight a little bit
do you know what i'm talking about i
didn't eat taco bell but i let it dance
on my taste buds into the palette and
also ruminate in my head a little bit
without eating any meat cheese or sour
cream
so i danced with it i danced with taco
bell in the pale moonlight but i didn't
[ __ ] with taco bell
so that just made it so i'm never eating
taco taco bell again so dude he won yes
he got out of that one [ __ ] yeah man i'm
tupac on this taco bell i ain't got no
[ __ ]
[Music]
you know you could listen to npr you
could talk to me and you could listen to
me and i'll have a [ __ ] 25 minute
segment on the baja blast man that's how
we do it this is how we do it
that's how we do it dude
i was with calvin today dude and he's
starting to say no they said those
terrible dues might happen a little late
and i guess they could say it's terrible
it's not terrible he just says no a lot
dude
it's hilarious he's well into two years
old and dude he's just been no
you want to [ __ ] hang out you want to
see my my friend came over you want to
see him no that's how he says it
okay like he's in a [ __ ] a french
film no
calvin you want some pasta no but he
wants it and he just doesn't know he's
just [ __ ] exercising his independence
calvin you want to go in the pool no as
he's walking to the pool just wants to
be a [ __ ] dick which is fine terrible
twos not even so terrible but it's fine
um
but today he really pulled a hard one
man i come downstairs in the morning
actually i got him up i put him
downstairs went back up came down and i
said hey calvin can you give dad that
hug good morning and he says
no i don't like dada
ah
sweaty sad
and i'll never forgot it
my son said
in my eyes
no
i don't like dada
and he said it after i asked for a hug
swati said
didn't take it personally
you know what i did
i said well calvin
that's okay you don't have to like me
but no matter what i love you
i don't think you really heard me
because i think he was busy running off
to try and find his peppa pig toys but
that's what i said and i meant it
how's you know how hard it is to not buy
[ __ ] from amazon
i mean you got the app you might as well
click away and [ __ ] i got two hair
products the other day and they came the
next day and dude now i'm [ __ ] loaded
with i'm stacking hair products to the
sky man hey but chris you look like you
never take a shower you ever heard of
product dork
hey he's so greasy dude ever heard a
pomade you [ __ ]
dork i can't help it because i'm [ __ ]
cool as [ __ ] looking like i belong on a
motorcycle but actually [ __ ]
you didn't even see this coming i got
four wheels
hey who's that guy with the leather
jacket where did he park his [ __ ]
motorcycle oh but dude
joke's on you
i got four wheels
but you look badass oh but i must live
on jokes on you avenue
because i got
double the amount of wheels you saw
you thought
so anyway um
oh i gotta talk about the [ __ ] attack
on dave chappelle jesus christ man
it's gonna be a long episode my babies
but
it's what happened
guy though they [ __ ] him up huh
they should have [ __ ] will smith like
up like that up i imagine they [ __ ]
will smith will smith just out here like
this
wow
with a broken arm on the stretcher
but i was in our robot
more like iii robot
two worst bits on incredible
uncongratulations has been in this
episode but we keep moving dude
we push forward right
um
yeah man
uh
the guy a guy was in did i talk to a guy
that was like i knew that that was gonna
happen i got one i got one of those
friends that was like i got one of those
friends that like that is the guy that's
like i was there i knew it was gonna
happen how about that you got those
friends
i'm like what bro he's like yeah let me
tell koi he text me i'll call you i'll
let you know i'm like all right [ __ ]
i don't even
all right let's have this conversation
so i can talk about on the podcast
calls me up pick it up so yeah i'm
hanging out with this dude and the dude
brushed past us
and uh they we saw him come in we saw
him hop the fence and one of my buddies
says why don't you to the security you
got to watch out for that guy and they
said ah don't worry about it the
concert's almost over dave chapel
leaving leaving soon and then the dude
ran up and and [ __ ] tackled dave
chappelle and the dude was so my buddy
was so mad and he's done mr i knew it
buddy you know
he's the mister i knew it buddy
and uh
and yeah i guess they're not charging
him as a felony
they're charging it as a misdemeanor and
dave chappelle which i'm surprised dave
chappelle is very uh open-minded and
very um
uh what do you call it uh
forgiving you know it he seems like a
very like forgiving open-minded
person and look he was attacked and it
was terrible and i do think the guy
should be charged as a felony because
you can't [ __ ] set a precedence that
everyone's going to get attacked on
stage if they're doing shitty jokes
because if that is true i'm public enemy
number one
i don't know if you know about this but
your boy's got haters
i don't know if you know about this but
if this guy doesn't get charged for at
least a misdemeanor if this guy doesn't
get charged for at least a missing
misdemeanor elliot then oh boy
i'm in trouble
when i show up to atlanta september 9th
get your tickets at crystallia.com when
i show up to boston at the wang almost
sold out
on november 12th
get your tickets at crystalia.com
when i show up to cheyenne wyoming or
denver colorado at the bellco
6 000 seats
november 5th
get your tickets to chris chrisdelia.com
we're opening up the upper deck
there's gonna be someone in there
that wants to rush the stage
on your
boy because i don't know if you know
about this
but you could fill my
haters
in the state of nebraska
psych
it's all good but seriously though i
need to get security
yeah man don't charge a stage if you
start charge the stage because of
something somebody said use a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know it's like
that's fine but blah what up homie you
know let my gun talk to you blow it up
homie that's fine
but i got he tucked in my waist dude i
should be the only comedian just
[ __ ] packing
just blab with a homie somebody comes up
blab what up homie whoa i was just
trying to give you some mushrooms that's
illegal too blah what up homie let my
let my let my gun have a combo with you
blah what up homie
let my gut talk to me blah what up homie
i was just coming to give you a [ __ ]
hug that gets me in trouble too dude i
don't know if you've read the articles
but i let my cat talk to me blah what up
homie
raleigh north carolina october 21st get
your tickets at crystalia.com so that's
what's up man
it's a long-ass episode man long-ass
[ __ ] episode
check out the new uh
podcast lifeline and do it i'm asking
you really do me a favor here i want to
see if it works
activate that algorithm
make friends in the comments
do you have something you want to talk
about share it
tell us your favorite restaurant
tell us your favorite hat you have
whatever you got to do
let's get your boy up jumped the boogie
with the numbers right
you in this cult are you out of this
cult are you a passive listener which we
enjoy but the real cult [ __ ]
you do the work you're the guys who are
going to be sitting outside of a log
cabin that we built by the way we hired
people but they're also in the cult so
we technically built it and we're going
to sit in that tall grass and we're
going to have some [ __ ] idea sharing
situations
so go to crystallia.com and get your
tickets
um
and uh i appreciate you guys
uh i'll be all of those places that i
said
plus more adding dates as well um
[Music]
and uh
adding dates as well doing um
i think i'm adding maine
for some reason i like maine though you
know
and uh where's my website here let's go
where's my freaking website let's go
chrisleya.com where am i going
uh
i mean dude it's not even it doesn't
even come up on google like i have my
website it's the ninth thing that's down
there
um
everything was ticketmaster washington
dc stockton california oakland
california peoria illinois rockford
illinois raleigh north carolina savannah
georgia denver cheyenne wyoming boston
jacksonville florida can't wait and guys
um get your merch
so it arrives
and wear that [ __ ]
at the uh at the show
hey guys that's the end of the episode
on youtube if you want to get the rest
of the episode the uncut version of this
episode go on over to
patreon.comcrystalia
there's plenty there there's extra
footage from the other with chris videos
we do another segment called review mode
and then there's also um
uh
one extra bonus episode a month
if you sign up on the patreon
patreon.comcrystallia
love to see you there and if not we'll
catch you here on youtube
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you